i don't need to impress you with a big
burrito it's confidence
tacos are confidence
[Music]
i convinced the people over at first
week feast to give me a talk show
i know you're getting hungry we're back
for another season of tacos contodo
which means more laughs more tacos more
comedians and
zoom lunch meetings tacos contour same
great show
just a little different because of cover
so how are we gonna eat tacos this
season through the mask
yeah no i'll try it
[Music]
making your own tortilla is a game
changer
[Music]
oh this is so good i think it's making
love in my mind i better try another one
just to make sure they're all the same
switches must be a mess in there
hi my name is johnny knoxville and this
is the taco truck
hit it boys what makes me happy about to
be a taquero is that i'm free
makes me feel like i'm doing something
good in this world it's how
i describe who i am if i can give you
five minutes or you just laugh that's my
only job in this world
the victory is the laughter you know
when you're on stage
have fun covenant ain't holding us back
tacos tacos
tacos
it's gonna blow you away